well there are plenty of frontline
healthcare workers who are still
hesitant about getting the vaccine in
fact an estimated
29 of all health care workers are really
having second thoughts about getting
that shot
so here's a look now at some of the
incentives that are being offered to
change people's minds
they've seen first hand the horrors of
the pandemic
still some health care workers are
hesitant about cobit 19 vaccines
but public health officials are working
to address their concerns about vaccine
safety my primary
message to health care professionals is
please get vaccinated
another barrier a mistrust of government
and medicine among some minorities
who make up about 40 percent of u.s
health care workers
stemming in part from our country's
history of dishonest medical experiments
on people of color jennifer stevenson is
an administrator at laredo hospital in
chicago when it comes to vaccines we've
been like the guinea pigs
jennifer did end up coming around then
this week
got her second dose what was effective
for me was actually
not only someone sitting down and
talking to me but actually
seeing leadership stepping up to the
plate and actually taking the vaccine
the hospital added a paid day off as a
reward
institutions across the country are
coming up with creative ways to convince
their staff to take the shot
houston methodist offers a 500 cash
incentive
and an atlanta nursing home chain
raffles off bonuses vacation
days and free tvs
now experts say more public health
education is really critical in order
for us to overcome this vaccine
hesitancy
both in health care workers and in the
general population